(gentle music)
- Hey, come on in.
(energetic music)
Yeah.
Push and Believe, you got it.
Andy, you and I are both from
the Seattle Washington area,
and so, you were
born in Seattle.
- Yes.
- And you began your comedy
participation in Seattle.
- Basically Seattle
comedy underground--
- That's where I started.
But it's not about me.
- I was going to--
- I need to be more selfless.
- Alright.
- I grew up in LA.
- Okay.
- I've skied once in my life.
I feel great today.
How are you doing?
- I'm good.
- What do you like to
do in your free time?
You're recently married.
- Recently married, one week.
- Congratulations.
(Clapping)
- Thank you, thank
you very much.
Nobody else?
(clapping)
Aright, thank you.
Thank you.
That felt good.
- Where'd you meet your wife?
J-Date?
I gotta do a joke, I
gotta keep it light.
I have to do that.
- I met her at open mic.
- She's a comedian?
- She's a comedian.
- I thought she was an actress.
I read my bio.
- Actress-Comedian.
- Where'd my bio,
where's my bio?
- [Andy] Front pocket.
- And the winner is,
for best cinematography.
Ang Lee, Life of Pi.
(dramatic music)
This is Andy's bio, says one
part dip, let me start over.
I have trouble reading, I
have adult-onset autism.
(laughs)
One part camp counselor.
One part debate team captain.
Andy Hames.
- Hames?
- That's what my guys put in.
- You gotta get new guys.
- I'm in town for a while,
I'm doing interviews,
I'm relaxing.
I'm actually gonna
have some downtime.
- Brody, have you ever
been to a Hard Rock Cafe?
- As a matter of fact,
yes, and you're telling me
they have a Hard Rock
Cafe here in Boston?
- There's one in Boston.
They have t-shirts,
they have chicken wings,
or chicken strips probably.
- I'm a strips guy.
- You're a strips guy?
- But I'll do wings.
Let's pick out one more.
Pick a brochure for
Brody to hang out,
and maybe I'll hang
out with you tomorrow.
JFK, Presidential
Library and Museum.
(sniffs) You got
me with that one.
You got me with that one.
- And there's a JFK cafe.
- And there's a cafe.
- Yeah.
- What are the hours?
- Nine to five.
♪ Workin' nine to five
- Where can we find
you on Twitter?
- @IMAndyHaynes.
- I know that.
- No, that's it.
@IMAndyHaynes.
- I am.
- I-M.
- I-M?
Spell it out.
- The letter I.
- I.
- The letter M.
- M.
- The word Andy.
- Andy.
- The word Haynes, with a Y.
- Haynes, with a Y.
- [Andy] I am Andy,
@IMAndyHaynes.
- I'm.
But no apostrophe.
- You can't put
apostrophes in there.
- (laughs) It's a bet.
Andy and Brody, your
new comedy team.
(cheerful music)
I am the Lance Armstrong
of Comedy Central videos,
and I'm sitting on my
testicle right now.
Subscribe, comment,
like me, DM me.
Tweet me.
Send me an IM.
Follow me home one night.
Pedal with me to
Twitter, to Facebook.
Like the videos.
Wanna go bike riding with me?
Do what it takes to go viral.
(upbeat music)